hallo herzlich willkommen meinert
ordnung
ich meine es ist schon um welches thema
es sich heute wieder haben und heute
geht es wieder um den valentinstag und
auch heute möchte ich wieder ein richtig
leckeres rezept machen
ich werde nämlich schöne cake pops
machen und die eignet sich einfach super
findet valentinstag denn mal ganz toll
vorbereiten und man kann sie einfach
schön verschenken an alle möglichen
leute jeden dem lieb hat und natürlich
an den oder die liebste und in der
herstellung sind sie auch relativ
einfach wir brauchen paar zutaten ich
werde zu den leckeren schokoladigen
rührteig herstellen aber ihr könnt auch
gerne wenn ihr zum beispiel sagt ich bin
ein zitronen fan könnte auf den zitronen
zeigt machen oder einfach irgendeine
andere geschmacksrichtung das bei mir
soll es einfach nur ein vorschlag sein
und ich zeig dir einfach mal die zutaten
vielen rührteig wir brauchen dafür 125
gramm zimmer warme butter 125 gramm
zucker drei eier 150 gramm mehl 50 gramm
speisestärke und 50 gramm kakaopulver
das ist jetzt back kakao und kein kaaba
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver und dann
noch eine flüssigkeit stadt könnte jetzt
entweder nur milch nehmen oder einfach
zum beispiel der milchkaffee oder eben
eine andere flüssigkeit nur ein café im
likör egal war und später brauche ich
für die creme etwas schokolade ich habe
jetzt hier 200 gramm vollmilchschokolade
200 gramm sahne und auch hier könnt ihr
gerne noch etwas likör oder kaffee oder
eine andere flüssigkeit benutzen einfach
ein bisschen geschmack reinzubringen und
die wichtigste zutat ist natürlich live
kommt natürlich in jedes rezept mit rein
aber haus mama noch mal ein stück mehr
und ich werde jetzt meinen rührteig in
der küchenmaschine machen aber es geht
auch super mit einem handrührgerät und
es ist hier ganz wichtig dass die
zutaten zimmertemperatur haben damit
sich einfach der teig schön verbindet
und nichts geredet wird erst mal die
butter mit dem zucker verrühren
einfach auf mittlerer aber ich versuche
jetzt einfach mit dem rhythmus die eier
mit einbringen und dann rühre ich gehe
einfach etwa drei minuten ein schlichter
kunden haben
durch die geschichte gibt und jetzt
versuche ich hier ganz kurz die
trockenen zutaten also einfach
backpulver mit dem mädels einfach damit
es jetzt keine klümpchen bildet und sich
schön verteilt
und jetzt kommen alle trockenen zutaten
mit in den teig schön rhythmisch gerührt
wurde dann höre ich das auf niedrigster
stufe ganz kurz unter und gebt dann auch
die flüssigkeit mit rein weil ich das
geld fertig und jetzt fühle ich den tag
einfach in eine vorbereitete form ich
nehme jetzt eine richtig große
springform damit der teig einfach sehr
schnell durch packt ihr könnt ihn
theoretisch auf einem blech backen oder
in einer anderen form in der kastenform
damit eine große springform damit
einfach wirklich schnell geht
denn ist sicher komplett egal denn der
kuchen wieder gleich wieder zerbröselt
und zerkrümelt und dann wird es hier
einfach kurz verteilt
und der richtig lecker nach kaffee
richtig schönes aroma und so wird er
jetzt im backofen bei 175 grad bei mir
jetzt für etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
gebacken
je nachdem in welcher form ihr fragt
macht auf jeden fall die stäbchen probe
und während der tat werde ich jetzt
gleich noch meine krebs zu bereiten
wegen unseres gleich wieder für die
füllung nehme ich jetzt einfach die
schokolade und haxe klein macht er
entweder mit einem messer oder mixer
nämlich demnächst schneller geht
in der zwischenzeit habe ich schon mal
die same hier aufgekocht und hab jetzt
den herd oder ausgemacht jetzt geht
einfach klein gehackte schokolade mit
dazu die kann sich dann nämlich in der
wanne auflösen und das was wir jetzt
gerade herstellen ist praktisch eine
kanal also das nimmt man aufgehört als
praline und füllung oder ich benutze es
auch immer ganz gerne um meine motiv
torten zu bestreichen bevor die zucker
decke drauf kommt einfach reingehen und
dann einfach mit einem schneebesen so
lange rühren bis sich die schokolade
komplett aufgelöst hat
und es geht relativ schnell weil die
schokolade richtig klein gehackt war und
jetzt kann ich sie einfach umfällt
einfach hier einen teller den ich vorhin
benutzt hatte auf dem geschirr machen
kann es hier drin nämlich schön abkühlen
und dann warte ich jetzt einfach nur
noch auf den kuchenteig lasst ihn auch
komplett abkühlen und dann sehen wir uns
einfach gleich wieder mein kuchenteig
ist jetzt abgekühlt und meine krems auch
abgekühlt und jetzt muss ich den teig
zerbröseln ich habe jetzt handschuhe an
ihr könnt aber ohne machen aber ich will
jetzt gleich die kuchen brösel mit dem
mit der creme verkneten und deswegen
ziehe ich da immer gern handschuhen
nehme ich mir einfach den teig und kann
ihn zu schreiben dann kribbelt es so
bislang annimmt da einfach die finger
noch mit dazu
es können jetzt einfach ganz grob mit
den fingern machen oft ich den rezepten
auch so dass das man einfach einen
fertig kuchen verwendet aber ich finde
ich einfach so schnell zusammengerührt
dass man einfach den schnell selber
machen kann bevor ich da jetzt losgehen
und irgendwie ein fertigkuchen kaufen
muss kann ich auch einfach die zutaten
schnell zusammen und habe einen eigenen
teig dann nehme ich dir einfach die
creme und gebt die sorte rüber
und da nehme ich auch noch die
flüssigkeit
jetzt wird es einfach so verknetet bis
es einfach eine richtig klebrige masse
ist die dann einfach zusammen bleibt
sobald ich sie zusammen drücke dürfte
auf keinen fall auch so viel flüssigkeit
rhein geben
ich hatte eben bisschen viel drin hab
einfach noch parcours in brüssel mit
rein gegeben
ich hab nämlich den zeigt zwei mal
gebacken weil ich später noch eine
portion machen so lecker was ist wenn
jetzt einmal vor sally der teig tisches
zu flüssig oder oder von der
grundsätzlich gut und du hast kein
zweiter kuchenteig mann du hast ja im
boden google immer kuchen dann kann man
einfach auch zum beispiel ein paar kekse
zerbröseln und die mit rein geben also
falls ihr mann zu viel creme oder
flüssigkeit da drin habt könnt ihr auf
jeden fall einfach keks bröseln dass der
teig ist ein fest addiert und der teig
gesetz von der konsistenz her so ihr
seht es auch die sich jetzt wie
praktisch so ein knetmasse schon
geworden sondern feuchte jetzt nehme ich
mir einfach ein eis fraktion ihrer das
ist ein mittelgroßer also nicht zu groß
und kann mir jetzt damit den teig
abstechen den zoo habe ich einfach den
vorteil dass meine kate fox ist
gleichmäßig groß werden im rollstuhl
eine mini kugel und dann wird es einfach
zwischen den hinten gerollt bis wir eine
schöne kugel haben und ich setze meine
dann hier einfach auf so ein torten
retter offenen eckigen sabine buck folie
drauf und ich wollte jetzt einfach mal
kurz fertig und dann werden sie für etwa
eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
gestellt damit die kugeln richtig kalt
werden und dann verarbeiten wir sie
gleich weiter und weisen wir dekorieren
wünsche kleine machen
jetzt macht schon jetzt nimmst dir in
die hand raus genau einmal drücken und
auf dem tisch trocken halten möchte
rollen cook zu einer kugel meine truppen
sind jetzt schön kalt und jetzt habe ich
hier bereits meine cake pops sticks die
gibt's einmal in fans meter länge zum
beispiel die gibt es von deco bank auch
im supermarkt und auch bei uns im shop
oder die gibt es auch in länger ich
hab's auch in 15 cm bei mir im shop und
ich werde jetzt für meine großen die 15
zentimeter sticks nehmen und für samaras
kleine einfach 10 cm sticks und jetzt
brauche ich natürlich noch etwas zu
überziehen
entweder kann man jetzt komme türe
benutzen in weiß vollmilch oder sagt
bitter oder man nimmt so wie ich hier
jetzt diese zuckerglasur und zwar gibt
es die einmal in weiß und in rosa die
sind jetzt auch von rico back und gibt
es auch im supermarkt und auch bei uns
und ich nehme jetzt natürlich die
rosinen weil ich das ja romantisch haben
möchte und deswegen kommt der user ganz
gut aber ihr könnt auch weiß nehme und
zum beispiel mit lebensmittelfarbe
passte auch die weiße ein werden in rot
oder blau oder grün schwarz was auch
immer ihr wollt und jetzt kann ich mir
einfach diese zuckerglasur in so eine
kleine schüssel und
jetzt einfach mal alle habt ihr einen
topf mit heißem wasser stehen und es
lastet jetzt kurz aufkochen und lasst es
dann darüber schmelzen
aber wenn ihr zum beispiel eine
mikrowelle habt können dann einfach
gesamte einfach die schlüssel in die
mikrowelle stellen dann natürlich eine
metallschüssel sondern du hast eine
glasschüssel es geht auf jeden fall viel
schneller ich hab das jetzt geschmolzen
und in der mikrowelle geht es übrigens
so wenn ihr das hier eine glasschale
habt gibt es rein bei höchster stufe
oder mittlerer stufe je nachdem wie hoch
ihre mittlerweile geht einfach 30
sekunden reinstellen wieder rausholen
durchführen und das einfach so lange bis
es eben geschmolzen ist das ist jetzt
ziemlich dickflüssig aber dafür dass ich
jetzt die sticks sitzt in die kugeln
rein stechen möchte ich es gut und
später mit muss einfach noch ein
bisschen flüssiger machen
jetzt geht es praktisch so ich nehme mir
einen cake pops stick und dunkle den
hier etwas so ein zentimeter tief rein
und geht dann herüber und
jeder richtig mittel sollen kate ob rein
und den stecke ich dann ungefähr bis zur
hälfte
und jetzt ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
die cake pops ticks einfach nochmal
meeting cake pops zusammen in den
kühlschrank stellen für etwa 15 minuten
damit sie schon fest werden denn
ansonsten kann es einfach passieren dass
die jetzt hier vom stapel darunter
fallen und das ist der fehler den oft
ganz viele machen und die cake pops
halten dann einfach nicht dran aber ich
nutze die zeit jetzt auch um eine deko
show vorzubereiten und was ich jetzt am
deko benutze zeige ich euch jetzt
einfach mal
ich benutze jetzt für die deko ein paar
streute ich habe zwei welche in rosa ein
paar perlen und in weiß und dann benutze
ich hier etwas modellieren schokolade
und zwar heißt die deko schock gibt es
auch im supermarkt und auch bei uns und
guckte mal was ganz besonderes drauf
gibt und zwar ist hier mein logo drauf
und da kam einfach mit dem handy sind
qr-code abscannen und da gibt es dann
ein handy wie es noch ganz viele rezepte
den von mir gibt das ist richtig cool
auch ein echtes produkt weil das modell
ihr schokolade ist einfach schokolade
mit etwas zucker und so weiter als spieß
um zucker zeigt nur eben mit schokolade
das heißt er schmeckt dann auch richtig
gut und man kann einfach super
verarbeiten aber sag ich euch gleich
dann benutze ich noch ein bisserl hart
peter kuvertüre und noch so ein paar
weiße zu kartons ruhig bereitet wie
gesagt die deko einfach ein bisschen vor
und modelliert schokolade ist einfach so
also die ich so verpackt und die kann
man sich hier mit einer palette zum
beispiel einfach unter schneiden dann
kannst du dann mit den händen verkneten
und er verteilt da ist einfach der
geschmack natürlich dass es eben
schokolade schmeckt aber auch dass ich
sie einfach immer wieder verkneten kann
das heißt selbst wenn sie mir
offen rumsteht trocknet sie nicht aus
denn ich tu dir ja praktisch durch wärme
aktivieren und durch werbe weich kneten
und sobald sie ihren kalt wird witze
hart und wenn wir mal was nicht gefällt
kann ich einfach wieder warm machen und
umformen
das ist echt super und ich nehme jetzt
eine einfache bis la rosa und ein
bisschen straße und weiß und nehmen wir
meine kleinen ausstecher die
herzschwäche und kann damit einfach
super süße herzen ausstellt jetzt kann
ich das hier einfach auf einer silikon
matte zum beispiel ausrollen und ihr
seht auch zum verkneten kein zelt kein
puderzucker wirklich gar nichts das
klebt auch nicht an den händen
so dünn wie ich möchte man kann sich
richtig dünn ausrollen das ist echt
super und jetzt nehme ich mir meine aus
sich jetzt nämlich den größten städte
ein paar häppchen aus
jetzt kann ich meine cake pops mit der
klasse über 10
aber ich habe vorhin schon gesagt diese
mails zu dickflüssig deswegen gebe ich
da einfach ein bisschen familien ein
paar - einfach kokosfett gibt es in
jedem supermarkt und da gebe ich mir
jetzt ein bisschen mit dazu und verrührt
es kurz und dadurch wird einfach
flüssiger und ich kann die cake pops
tieren besser überziehen weil die glasur
dem flüssiger ist und sich besser darum
legen sieht man jetzt auch hier ganz gut
dass sie gleich flüssiger wird sally ich
habe auch im cache pop gemacht sich die
cache von murat des toten popstars wie
pop3 murat wie das riecht das ist ja
total eklig weil ich habe hier lauter
schokoladen dinger vor mir und jetzt
richtig einfach knoblauch wurst
wahnsinnig grad echt nicht gut wissen
cake pops ist
und ich nehme jetzt hier meine cake pops
da muss man ab und zu so ein bisschen im
finger nachdrücken falls und das eben
einfach zu gerade geworden ist und jetzt
kann ich das nehmen wollte hier rein
toten whistler trotz trüber laufen
lassen
jetzt richtet und lasst den rest einfach
runter laufen dann verteilt sich das
gleichmäßig und dann stecke ich den ganz
kurz zum trocknen hier auf den styropor
ich hatte jetzt das styropor mit ein
bisserl geschenkpapier eingepackt aber
ich werde es später noch mal austausche
und schönes geschenkpapier drum herum
machen einfach damit sie eben hübscher
aussieht wenn jetzt über ziehe ich mir
einfach hier so ein paar
die cake pops hills und bisschen
angetroffen wird muss ich sie gleich
weiterverarbeiten
damit meine deko überhaupt aufkleben
kann jetzt habe ich hier zum beispiel
bisschen zeit später kuvertüre
geschmolzen und lass dir jetzt einfach
mal drüber laufen habe ich übrigens auch
wissen teilnehmen können
und da las jetzt ein paar zuckerperlen
drüber und fangen sie einfach unten in
der schüssel wieder auf das feld so eine
einfache methode des rollos
oder ich nehme hier mein herzchen
also ich zeige euch einfach so eine idee
ich finde ja das ist so eine richtig
schöne geschenkidee auch die man einfach
so zum valentinstag verschenken kann
übrigens habe ich euch schon mal erzählt
was ich überhaupt formulare film
geschenkt bekommen habe samira ich habe
die sanierer geschenk mit dir habe ich
dir geschenkt aber unser erstes
wahnsinns geschenke war ein baum und
wird daher das war mein erstes und mein
letzter verschenkt da machen wir noch
nicht verheiratet da hat man sich noch
mehr gegeben
29 90 minuten denn zwar globus moslems
das weiß ich nicht in form eines
ansturms letzte geschenk aber bei uns
ist es ja nicht so wichtig mit den
geschenken weil ich habe schon erwähnt
hat bei uns jeden tag valentinstag ist
unser leben und auch ohne geschenke du
solltest nicht gesagt
auch meine arbeitskollegen schaut es aus
senken und dabei schließen ich konnte
jeder wissen dass ich mich über alles
liebt man sich alle anlagen sie mich
anders
der ist pervers der liegt seine frau ja
und dann wird dann allemal her geht
sogar so gern stars nicht sagen aber ihr
könnt mir immer schreiben was ihr oder
was euer besonders des valentinstags
geschenk mal war ich denk da gibt es
ganz viel ganz wieder anregungen für
dich dass du dir einfach mal was
abgucken kann von anderen und oder ihr
könnt ihr mal schauen was ihr schönes
geschäft habe dass er auch matisse meine
cake pops sind jetzt alle schön
getrocknet und ihr seht ihr ziel schon
ich hab mir was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich hier einfach so ein
großes weckglas genommen also ein
einmachglas
der zucker streusel rhein gegeben also
zuckerperlen
hier vorne ist so eine folie und eine
tafel folie auf die kamera dann mit so
kreide stiften drauf schreiben und dann
habe ich einfach ein bändchen kühlung
gegeben und kann den kopf einstecken
weil ich finde dass ist einfach eine
super geschenkidee und darin sieht es
einfach super dekorativ aus das macht
deutlich was herr oder morath ja
natürlich meine ich mich sehen wollen
ich weiß ob das was für ein mann ist
sitzen cake pops geschenkt zu bekommen
wieso hätte es kommt von herzen und
liebe geht durch den magen
der zeuge rief ins ist toll aus wie mama
wie freundinnen oder für die oma hallo
wieso für die oma für die mama witt
freundin wünsch dich jetzt net freue
mich dass schenken
ja natürlich will ich mich freuen waren
sie nicht
ich wäre aus dem häuschen glücklich
gemacht
lediglich das ist toll ganz ehrlich mein
essen nein dafür dass der zur gemeinde
statt
jetzt kommt dann kann ich mal eingegeben
oder die perle fixed anmelden
denen darf weiß ab und dann zeigte die
kamera auge
okay ist meine meinung echt klasse
und die können jetzt natürlich noch wenn
man sie zum beispiel transportieren
möchte einfach in etwas folie einpacken
und hat mir echt zu das perfekte
geschenk von zu hause aus gemacht und
ich finds echt richtig schön da steckt
ganz viel liebe mit drin und ich finde
cake pops sind auch immer eine gute
möglichkeit um reste zu verwerten
das heißt immer wenn wir zum beispiel
kuchen reste haben mama kuchen oder in
die anderen trockenen fuhren dann kann
ich dann einfach mit so einer creme
vermischen und kann cake pops machen
ihr müsst ihr jetzt aber auch nicht
unbedingt auf und stil drauf machen
sondern ich mache oft einfach nur kleine
kügelchen die kann man dann in zug ein
kleine pralinen förmchen reinsetzen und
dann hat man eben auch eine schöne
resteverwertung
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefallen hat fand sie die kickbox nach
macht dann schickt mir doch einfach ein
bild auf instagram oder auf facebook da
freue ich mich sehr darüber
über eure ideen über eure gestaltung und
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir einfach
das nächste mal wieder einschaltet dann
kriegst du mich wieder richtig leckeres
klar